vous entends tu es à ces divins
après ça tout le reste les mondanités et
cocktails les robes du soir les général
et puis j'étais la côte d'azur saint
tropez et pita les rats y en a
ras-le-bol ras-le-bol cette année jean
et moi on n'en pouvait plus
on a fui jusqu en auvergne au fin fond
du cantal une ferme au bout d'un village
d'une saleté d'une bourde dément
des femmes en noir sans art et dante et
porte encore des seaux d'eau le visage
creusé ravagé sillonné comme la terre
génitrice convient de labourer les vieux
paysan immobile sur leur banc de pierre
moussu ne prononçant pas un mot pendant
des journées entières l'instant
seulement dans un autre le gène rue de
leur salive comme on jette sa semence et
est d'un pathétique et d'une
authenticité souvent jean et moi nous
nous regardions les urnes mais c'est pas
possible ça existe encore tous mais
c'est merveilleux faut en profiter très
vite c'est merveilleux merveilleux
et puis un soir ce soir là je ne suis
pas prêt d'oublier
jean est tombé dans le tas de fumier se
barrent le chemin conduisant à la ferme
je l'attendais j'étais à table
comme une chatte affamés je la paie du
lait bourru en écoutant la mélopée
nostalgiques des moutons revenant du
pâturage lorsque jean est entré cette
ode j'ai dit ajoutant supplie ne fait
pas un pas de plus je ne supporterais
pas c'était trop trop d'un seul coup je
suis levé mon coeur battait violemment
petit à petit je me suis approché de
gens je les ai eu mes longs je crois
bien que j'ai pleuré j'ai dit à jean tu
te rends compte bien seule envie
journaux mettent en tête encore
l'essence la poussière la ville
l'horreur et maintenant dix ans mais
c'est ça la vérité jean mon chéri nous
tenons la vérité
je défaille est il m'a serré très fort
entre lui il a posé sa main puis
censure- macro et ma vie vient d'une
voix sourde et animale il m'a entraîné
dehors je suis laissée happer par les
clameurs indécent de cette chaude nuit
d'été avec mes sabots ma longue robe
paysanne en coton bleu délavé je
trébuche et dans la boue ils purent rien
c'était bon nous avons traversé l'écurie
respirer ses senteurs
il m'a semblé que j'étais ivre nous
avons hâte à la grange dont il a ouvert
la porte il m'a poussé dans le foin de
tout côté dehors dedans ce n'était que
miaulements gémissements allaitement
devait en rut
quand nous nous sommes relevés jean et
moi après deux ou trois sailly a pas l
tout mêlé à mes cheveux défaits et
anneaux toison intime
j'avais acquis une certitude
à partir de cet instant plus rien ne
sera comme un désormais je ne pourrai
plus faire l'amour
en france on dit toujours la culture la
culture et les bonnes mais je me
souviens autrefois chez mon grand-père
il y avait accroché dans le salon
3 mené 3 2 gars 3 renoir de somptueuses
tapisseries
dieu merci c'est moi qui ont hérité pas
beaucoup de discussions et bien qu'ils
épousseter chaque jour ses magnifiques
tableaux c'était lemon il y avait de
quoi leur forme et nous il semble les
porcelaines de sens et les fautes et les
canapés louis saez ou la splendide
bibliothèque remontée moi mon oreiller
ni strass et l'argenterie cristaux et
bibelots les bisous c'était pas de la
culture une leçon d'aaa comparables dont
elle bénéficiait gracieusement sans
débourser un centime
et les conversations à table ces
répliques c'est un slot de l'élite dont
elle pouvait saisir des bribes aux vols
tout en présentant les plats c'était pas
de la culture ballon laissez moi rire
voulez-vous me dire ce qu'elles font à
présent elle travaille à l'usiné où elle
fera quand n'importe quoi des portugais
pire elle se 30 dans le métro de la
marmaille gens soient bien du plaisir et
elle habite sur une demande en banlieue
c'est agréable dans un chu ils aiment
tellement hideux que voix passant devant
refuse de les voir au lieu de loger dans
une de ses chambres de service qu'on
s'arrache à prix d'or et qu'on loue très
bien très bien les petits étudiants
charme
elle ne voulait plus de nos chambres et
bien nous avons reprises ouah je vois
dans mon immeuble je les ai tout rafler
et genlis à l'appartement x qui lie pas
sont très amusants qui ravit tous aux
abris
vous entendez cediv après ça tout le
reste les mondanités cocktails et robbie
soir les général et puis l'été la côte
d'azur saint tropez cp tolérable il y en
a ras-le-bol ras-le-bol ras-le-bol cette
année jean et moi on n'en pouvait plus
on a fui jusqu en auvergne au fin fond
du cantal une ferme au bout d'un village
d'une saleté d'une beauté dément les
femmes en noir sans âge et dante est par
contre encore des seaux d'eau le visage
creusé ravagé sillonné comme la terre
génitrice convient de labourer les vieux
paysan immobile sur leur banc de pierre
moussu ne prononçant pas à un mot
pendant des journées entières lançant
seulement de temps à autre le jet de
rues de leur salive comme on jette sa
semence
c'est d'un pathétique et d'une
authenticité souvent jean et moi de nous
regardions et nous disions mais c'est
pas possible ça existe encore mais c'est
merveilleux faut en profiter très vite
s'énerver merde
et puis un soir ce soir là je ne suis
pas prêt de l'oublier
jean est tombé dans le tas de fumier ou
barre le chemin conduisant à la ferme
je l'attendais j'étais à table comme une
chatte affamés je l'appelle et bourru en
écoutant à la mélopée nostalgiques des
moutons ou venant du pâturage
lorsque jean est entré cette odeur cette
odeur j'ai dit à jean jetons supplie ne
fait pas un pas puis je ne le
supporterais pas c'était trop trop d'un
seul coup je me suis levé mon coeur
battait violemment petit à petit je me
suis approché de joux je l'aimais
longuement je crois bien que j'ai pleuré
j'ai dit alors tu te rends compte ya
seulement huit jours nos vêtements
s'entête encore l'essence la poussière
la ville horreur et maintenant tu sens
mais si ça la vérité jean mon chéri nous
tenons la vérité
je t'ai fayet
il m'a serré très fort contre lui il a
posé sa main puis censure- ma krupp
il m'a dit viens une voix sourde et
animale il m'a entraîné dehors je suis
laissée happer par les clameurs 20
décembre de cette chaude nuit d'été avec
mes sabots ma longue robe pisano coton
bleu délavé jeu très du c'est dans la
boue ils purent 1 c'était bon nous avons
traversé l'écurie va respirer ses
senteurs il m'a semblé que j'étais ivre
nous avons hâte à la grange dont il a
ouvert la porte il m'a poussé dans le
choix de tous poussés dehors dedans cdt
comme yulon gémissements allaitement de
16 ans quand nous nous sommes revus mais
j'en ai moi après deux ou trois saillie
n'a pas eu tout mêlé à mes cheveux les
faits et à nos trois ans intime
j'avais acquis une certitude à partir de
cet instant
plus rien ne sera comme avant désormais
je ne pourrai plus faire l'amour paris
claire bonsoir mais 82 un an déjà que
les roses sont au pouvoir
qu'évoque pour vous cet anniversaire
nous sommes allés le demandent et madame
du château pâtissière à pauvres sur mer
nous on aime notre métier mon mari les
pattes ici moi je suis à la caisse pour
nous même si aujourd'hui on a la nex
devant la plage et qu'on fait des bonnes
saisons avec les gaufres faut pas
oublier que joël et moi quand on a
démarré on n'avait pas ça et maintenant
faut dire ce qui est on n'est pas bon
pourquoi
parce que comme la gauche est passé
nos fonds de commerce
adios
tous les couches de tasses ou la musique
les blues chanté si les petits bonnets
très avenant les moules à pompons tout
ce qui fait la vraie pâtissière bye bye
tout le monde en gris souris on sera pas
à son avantage
moi pas tranquille
d'ailleurs dès maintenant se décider
comme la gauche est passé les
certificats de baptême des gosses dans
le four à pain ça laisse pas si tous les
gars tout genre mariages communions
baptêmes trop droite
ne plus prendre ce risque qui les
refusent je préfère rater des ventes
aujourd'hui que de risquer de me faire
descendre demain pour des bêtises
encore un comme la gauche est positif
avec joël le soir on travaille la pâte
d'amande
croyez moi c'est pas commode enfin
heureusement ça commence à rendre on a
line in au bolchoï montée surgit noise
qui est au poil mais joël a encore
beaucoup de boulot avec sa pièce montée
karl marx à cheval sur le kremlin
c'est la barbe en chantilly au bout de
20 minutes ça dégringole forcément à 100
et du travail mais comme dit joël comme
la gauche est passée font miette du côté
du marteau
mais beaucoup de matches comme ça juste
diane 1
à 16h20 la langue cgc parce que tu
trouves comment roger pro vie à dos de
ma grosse bouffe jédir je viens c'est
parce que je suis pas insensible
magazine ils disent de actuelle marceau
forcer sur le rose
seulement je me raconta facile ça fait
une guerre juste bien je préfère que tu
me dis dans mes camarades comme enjeu
des riches j'ai horreur de la vulgarité
et pic à 6 ans avec des pics à maman je
vais défiler mon fiancé un bon j'arrive
à me semble me disent ça ma porte à clé
dsk n'a plus atteint depuis à la porte
c'est mince pies ces personnes mad men
il a le rire c'est parti c'est peut-être
ma fiancée torpiller son paraphe ou
quelques cieux et puis je veux pas nous
est pas qu est ce qui me retient comme
un jardin comme je n'appelle pas de
produits disent mince de dépression film
à thèse d'après tata bien josiane junte
un barouf junte on vous parlait que
c'est un genre de meurtrier à jeudi mais
ce n'est pas avec est ce que j'ai de
venir je suis toute seule dans ma petite
soeur heureusement alors que saragosse
dame au chapeau ne sais pas si je vais
rester parce que j'ai à dire une chose
n'a pas tendu il m'a remis de l'activité
de la comprendre sian alors a saisi dès
demain là que je me dis pour un g2 lac
la corse malchanceuse maintenant je vous
rappeler de l'ofj avait saisi un
presse-papier j'ai passé la nuit blanche
jusqu'à 7 heures sur mon lit tu vas
comme suppléant alors quand vous avez
vos allocations la patronne et si vous
n'avez pas raconter votre centre il ya
un an j'étais un bull je m'énerve
rendement c'est pas possible j'ai dit
mais enfin jamie d'avoir fait ça de
faire mon travail c'est un brushing a
pas de terre ou l'or tuvalu perçu comme
un barbier
c'est vrai c'est pas qu'il a vécue masse
tu sais que j'ai toujours aussi dingue
de journée moi je craque ça ne passera
pas j'ai entendu dire qu'il avait déjà
dit qu écrivent aux vedettes
alors je sais pourquoi décrète pas c'est
vrai que je suis pas pu masquer une note
j'ai fait une lettre c'est qu'ils te dit
que j et demi ça veut dire jamais
retient pas pipi un jeu fait drôlement
bien que j'aie papier shehata monoprix
attend qu est ce que j ennemis ben si je
me rappelle même plus que j'aime me dit
non c'est pas vrai c'est la meilleure de
l'année
je sais pas si c'est la chaleur ou quoi
mais je suis quand même fêté en ce
moment à oui si si ça marche bien en
cause un avis émis pour commencer mon
génie je t'aime mon johnny je te veux
juste qu'elle a mises oscillent entre
parenthèses jonnhy ton sexe de jausiers
dhr c'est par ans avait marre mais
seulement je te veux c'est quand même de
réserver ces génies comme qui est beau
on se voit qu'il dépose ce travail au
pelvis
moi c'est simple quitte à chiny je
contrôle plus j'ai mis au sida liberté
c'est mon bonheur ça c'est beau comme
formule moi je vais trouver comme ça
j'ai réfléchi je suis une pas comme ce
sera pas que c'est toute façon pourquoi
que je lui va s'arranger les dents parce
que mon fiancé dit que simplicime en
charme